اهلا بكم الى هذه التغطيه المتواصله
427 قتيلا على الاقل حسب قتل الاشتباكات
في السودان التي دخلت اشتباكاتها يومها
الحادي عشر بينهم
291 مدنيا كما ذكرت نقباء اطباء السودان
مؤخرا ونقابه اطباء السودان اليوم خذنا
جديده بواسطه امريكيه سعوديه لحقد الدماء
وسماح لعمليات اجلاء امنه وبعد ساعات من
دخولها حيز التنفيذ خرجت اتهامات من الدعم
السريع لقوات الجيش بخرق هذه الغده
[موسيقى]
السودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
اذا الولايات المتحده اعلنت عن هدنه في
السودان الهدنه دخلت حيز التنفيذ اعتبارا
من منتصف ليل الاثنين الثلاثاء وزير
الخارجيه
سابقا الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع على
تطبيق وقف اطلاق نار لمده اثنتين وسبعين
ساعه على مستوى البلاد بدءا بمنتصف ليل
الرابع والعشرين من ابريل لكن ناشد طرفي
النزاع بالسودان
لتنفيذ فوري لوقف اطلاق النار وبشكل كامل
القوات المسلحه السودانيه اعلنت انها
وافقت على تطبيق وقف اطلاق النار على
مستوى البلاد بناء على وساطه سعوديه
امريكيه وذلك من اجل فتح ممرات انسانيه
وتسهيل حركه المواطنين والمقيمين وتمكينهم
من قضاء احتياجاتهم والوصول الى
المستشفيات والمناطق الامنه واجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه
من جانبه تعامين مجلس التعاون الخليجي
جاسم البديوي طرفي النزاع في السودان الى
سرعه المضي قدما تجاه وقف العمليات
العسكريه والتحلي باقصى درجات ضبط النفس
وتجنب التصعيد وتغليب مصلحه الشعب
السوداني وضمان امنه واستقراره والحفاظ
على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده الى
الاتفاق الايطالي الهاتف للوصول الى اعلان
سياسي
معنى من الخرطوم الصحفي خالد الفكري سيد
خالد اهلا بك هل لا زالت الهدنه صامده في
الخرطوم
نعم يعني اعتقد انه منذ الصباح
تحلق لي الطيران وبعض الاصوات المتخيله
دون تحديد المواقع ولكن يعني يبدو ان هذه
الهدنه
ستكون هي صامده اكثر التي كانت من قبلي
وزاره الحزبان ان الان هناك تدخل واضح
وجديه تعلقت مع الدول الولايات المتحده
على لسان وزير خارجيه ان هذه الهدنه
مطلوبه بقوه وان هناك
ايضا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وشركاء في الاقليم مما يعزز فرضيه ان تكون
هذه الهدنه بمثابه تمجيد
يعني وقف عدائيات وربما مفاوضات لاحقه سنن
ان ربما الرياض تستضيف
الجمرلين من خلال ايام قادمات
هذه الفتنه او
الوضع الانساني من خلال امنه ومن خلال
ايضا محاوله
ايجاد معالجات لكثير من التشوهات على عبد
الله خاصه متعلقه
بالجثث ونقلها
الجرحى وتقديم حتى العونه الانساني
للمحتاجين فاذا يبدو ان الان هناك فرص
اوسع واكبر
لهذه حتى تكون صامده وتطلب ان تكون لاحقا
وقفه عدائيات بما يمكن ان يجعل هناك
مفاوضات ممكنه بين الطرفين
خالد ساهمت بشكل كبير في اجلاء المزيد من
الرعايه الاجانب من العاصمه السودانيه
ولكن ماذا عن الوضع الانسان المتعلق بمن
تبقى في الخرطوم
نعم يعني حتى هذه اللحظه الوضع الانساني
ما زال يشهد تعقيدات بارده وكبيره
والوطني مخيفه ومغلق في ظل الان يعني ذات
الصحه والمنظمات العامه في القطاع الصحفي
تتحدث عن خروج عشرات المستشفيات والمشافي
وتعرض بعضها
الاضرار المباشره وايضا هناك نفسي في
الكادر الخشفي ونقصي في المستهلكات الطبيه
فاذا يعني الحال يتدنى الى اسهم ممكن ان
يوصف بانه كارث رغمي ما قالت به وزاره
الخرقوم بانها حاولت ايجاد مشافي بديله من
خلال محاوله اسعاف فوائد خل المراكز
الصحيه في عدد من المناطق الخرطوم حتى
تقدم الخدمه ولكن دون شك هذا لن يشفع يشفع
لها في في حزبان مثل هذه الحرب والحرب
لعمليات وتدخلات عاجله في المستشفيات او
المراكز الصحيه في المناطق هي تقدم خدمات
يعني بسيطه ولا تعدوا يعني
كافه الاجهزه المطلوبه للتدخل الجراح
العالي او تقديم خدمه الطوارئ كما ينبغي
وفق المعايره الدوليه فاذا الان هناك ايضا
يعني شحم كبير جدا في اسئله الاستهلاكيه
هناك صفوف طويله من الخبز
امام المقادير وايضا هناك يعني نقص حاد في
الوقود وارتفاع يعني خرافي لاسعار اللتر
فاذا
لتدخلات يعني بالامس من مبعوثه او من
مسؤوله
لغات الامريكيه بانهم بسبب توفير امداد
وجيتري
الاغاثي وتقديم مساعدات انسانيه عادله
تساهم هذه الهدنه في الوصول الى ذلك ولكن
كصحفيه سودانيين من داخل العاصمه الخرطوم
هل اتضحت صوره بالنسبه لكم فيما يتعلق
بمناطق وجغرافيه السيطره لكلا الطرفين
نعم يعني اعتقد ان حتى هذه اللحظه
ظل الاشكاليات المتعلقه بتقييد حركه
الاعلام بشكل عام والصحفي بشكل خاص ومخال
تعرضهم
لما يمكن ان يتعرضوا له من خلال هذه الحرب
اعتقد انه يصعب بالتكون يعني سيطرت كل طرف
على الاماكن الحليبيه والحساسه وان كان
هناك انتشارا الان اكثر للدعم السريع في
الاحياء لذلك نشاهده من خلال يعني ننقله
ومن شهود عيان في عدد من الاحياء ان الدعم
السريع اصبح بشكل اكبر له انتشار في
الاحياء الشرقيه على الاقل من نطابق الطوم
سواء كانت الكويت او المعموره او برج او
الطائف او العمارات بجانب ايضا هناك وجود
له في اجزاء من احياء غربي ام درمان بجانب
ايضا هناك ايضا يوجد له في شركه النيل
وذلك مقابل
للقوات المسلحه التي لها انتشار اكبر في
مساحه تتعلق بالمناطق الحيويه للجيش سواء
كانت في في المدرعات والسجره وهذه المناطق
او في منطقه المهندسين وما جاورها من
مناطق عسكريه حيويه كان الدعم السريع هو
الان اعتمد على سياسه الانفتاح في الاحياء
وتركي
المواقع الحيويه والعسكريه الى الى القوات
المسلحه واعتقد ان هذا الامر يعني يلقي
بظلال سالبه على الامن والامن المواطن
هناك العام مخالفه شكاوي يعني كثير من
اعتداءات من مواطنين للدعم السريع على
منازلهم او مخاوف من وجودهم في الاحياء
وتعرض بعض الاحياء للطيران الحربي كما كان
بالامس في الكلاكله حيث يعني ان هناك
منزلي حقيبه عدد كبير من افراد الدعم
السريع ويتخذ خليه للاتصالات وتعرض الى
ضرب ضربه جويه مما يعني فاقم الازمه
الازمه الازمه في محيط السكن وادى الى
سقوط عدد من القتلى والجرحى فاذا الان
الامر يبدو صعيبا على القوات المسلحه في
السيطره على الدعم السريع الذي هو الان
يتسلل الى المنازل بل احتل بعض المنازل بل
الان نحن شاهدنا قرانا تغريده للقياد
السابق لحضور والتغيير امجد فريق الذي قال
ان الدعم السريع استولى واحتل منزله في
ضاحيه بحري
ووسط وسط الامر بالمغذي وبينما نجد ان
مستشار مستشار
فارس النور يقول ان قواته لا تقدم على
الدخول المنازل والاطلاع على المواطنين
واخراجهم بينما يعني هذه وهذا كله في اطار
التصريحات المتضاربه من كافه الاطراف
المشاركه في هذا النزاع الصحفي خالد الفكي
شكرا جزيلا لك نذكر اعزائي المشاهدين ببعض
العوائل التي تشاهدون على شاشه العربيه
وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه تعلن البدء في
اجلاء مواطنيها جوا ووزير خارجيه بريطانيا
يقول باننا نتواصل مع راعينا في السودان
بشكل مباشر بشان مسارات
الاجلاء الهدنه اذا ما زالت صامده الى حد
كبير في الخرطوم على الرغم من سماع ذوي
قذائف واشتباكات بالاسلحه ثقيله في
العاصمه السودانيه صباح اليوم كما افاد
مراسلنا من هناك طبعا مصادر العربيه ايضا
تحدثت عن ان مصر شددت الاجراءات الامنيه
حول سفارتها بالخرطوم واعضائها منذ ليله
امس وبالخصوص بعد مقتل احد دبلوماسيه
بنيران مجهوله في العاصمه السودانيه وطبعا
هذه الاجراءات الامنيه المشدده رافقها طلب
من دبلوماسيه المصريين واعضاء السفر
المتبقين في العاصمه هناك بعدم التحرك الا
للحالات الضروريه اذا الهدنه ما زالت
صامده رغم ما سمع من ذوي قضايقه واطلاق
رصاص متوقع متقطع في العاصمه السودانيه
صباح اليوم
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اعلن في تغريده على تويتر ان
المملكه ستواصل مع الاشقاء في السودان
ستتواصل لتامين ممرات امنه لاجلاء رعايه
الدول الصديقه والشقيقه كما اكد الامير
فيصل بن فرحان مواصله المملكه في اجراء
رعايه الدول التي تقدمت بطلب مساعده
مواطنها ونقلهم لاماكن امنه
وكانت قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه استقبلت
في جده سفينه سعوديه قادمه من بورتسودان
نقلت رعايه الدول العربيه واجنبيه
[موسيقى]
اربعه ايام منذ بدايه اجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ورعاي الدول الاجنبيه
والعربيه والافريقيه من السودان الى خارج
السودان هنا في مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه
السودان ما زالت مئات العائلات الاجنبيه
ورعاي الدول العربيه والافريقيه
والاوروبيه تواصل توفيق اوضاعها في هذا
المركز بمدينه بورسودان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نسقت معها عديد الدول العربيه
والافريقيه والاوروبيه من اجل توفيق اوضاع
رعايه هذه الدول بغيه الخروج بهم من شرق
السودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومنها الى بقيه دول العالم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه قالت بانها نسقت مع
الجيش ومع مختلف الجهات هنا في السودان
ونسقت مع عديد الدول العربيه والافريقيه
والاوروبيه حتى يتسنى لمئات الرعايه
الخروج
عبر البحر وعبر الطيران وصولا الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ومنها الى عدد من الدول
هذه الجهود المستمره منذ اربعه ايام يمضي
فيها التنسيق المشترك بين الجيش وبين
الشرطه وبين مختلف الوحدات الفنيه
والاداريه التابعه للجيش والشرطه من اجل
انجاز هذه العمليه اجلاء مئات والاف
الرعايه والدبلوماسيين للدول الاجانب في
السودان بعد اشتداد الاشتباكات العسكريه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع يتوقع ان تمضي
هذه العمليه خاصه وان هنالك برقيات ورسائل
تصل الى الجيش لتمهيد خروج مئات من
الرعايه والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من السودان
عبر الشرق الى خارج البلاد نزار البغداوي
لقناتها العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
لم يتوقع سودانيون ان تتحول الخلافات
السياسيه يوما ما في بلادهم الى معارك
مفتوحه وسط احيائهما السكنيه وبين بيوتهم
لكن الوضع اقل ما يمكن وصفه بانه مفجع وان
لم تكن صور تعكس تفاصيل ما يجري في
الميدان بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء او خدمات
الاتصال
وتنقل الروايات المروعه بعضا من معاناه
العاصمه وقاطرها الذين يبلغ عددهم خمسه
ملايين شخص
ان يتحول شخص الى جثه هامده على سرير باحد
المستشفيات ويبقى هناك لايام منسيا مشهد
بات مالوفا في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
ليس اقل قسوه خيار ترك العلاج والهرب من
غرفه اصبحت شبه موبوءه الى مواجهه التراشق
الناري الذي لم يفلت البعض منه حتى اللحظه
لم تتحقق فعليا اي هدنه بين الاطراف
المتقاتله امر تسبب بانهيار شبه كامل
لنظام الرعايه الصحيه وادى الى امتلاء
المشارح والشوارع بالجثث حتى المنشات التي
ابقت ابوابها مفتوحه معرضه لخطر الاغلاق
في اي لحظه بل وتعاني نقصا حدا في
المستلزمات الطبيه لاسيما اكياس الدم
والمعدات الجراحيه فضلا عن غياب الوقود
لتشغيل المولدات الكهربائيه وحتى سيارات
الاسعاف
[موسيقى]
الحياه
هو تحذير منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله من
تسبب انقطاع التيار الكهربائي باتلاف
لقاحات وجرعات انسولين تقدر باكثر من 40
مليون دولار كرم حناوي العربيه
مصر وجهت اعضاء سفارتها في الخرطوم بعدم
التحرك الا لحالات الضروره كما شددت
الاجراءات الامنيه حول سفارتها بالخرطوم
واعضائها منذ ليله امس الخارجيه المصريه
كانت اكدت مقتله مساعد الملحق الاداري
المصري بسفارتها في الخرطوم معلنه ان
بعثتها ستواصل عملها ومسؤوليتها في اجراء
المواطنين المصريين وذكرت مصادر للعربيه
ان هناك تنسيقا مع الجانب السوداني لفتح
تحقيق في مقتل احد اعضاء السفاره المصريه
بعد ان طلبت القاهره مزيدا من التوضيحات
حول ملابسات الحادث وقالت المصادر انه
سيتم نقل جثمان مساعد الملحق الاداري على
احدى الطائرات البصريه لدفنه في مصر وفقر
المصادر فقد تم تشديد الاجراءات الامنيه
حول السفاره المصريه بالتنسيق بين
الجانبين المصري والسوداني لتامين عناصر
واعضاء السفاره المصريه وتحركاتها خلال
الساعات المقبله بشكل اكبر
السعوديه اعرب عن تعازيها لمصر بوفاه
مساعد الملحق الاداري بسفاره القاهره في
الخرطوم وجددت وزاره الخارجيه دعوه
المملكه الى وقف العمليات وتجنب التصعيد
والعوده الى الاتفاق الايطالي الهادف
للوصول الى اعلان سياسي يحقق الامن
والاستقرار
قوات الدعم السريع اعلنت في بيانها انها
ستتعاون مع مصر لكشف الحقائق حول مقتل
مساعد الملحق الاداري بالسفاره المصريه
واضافت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان لها ان
ما وصفته بيد الغدر التي امتدت للفقيد
ارادت ان تعبث بالعلاقات الاخويه بين
الشعبين شقيقين كانت الخارجيه المصريه
اعلنت مقتله مساعد الملحق الاداري محمد
الغراوي خلال توجهه من منزله الى مقر
السفاره لمتابعه اجراءات الاجلاء الخاصه
بالمواطنين المصريين في السودان
من القاهره محمد ابو الفضل مدير تحرير
جريده الاهرام والمختص في الشام الافريقي
سيد محمد اهلا وسهلا التغطيه المتواصله
نحن اليوم في اليوم الحادي عشر من
الاشتباكات بعد عجز اي من الطرفين على حسم
الصراحه الاجواء مواتيه الان
لاستمرار هذه الهدنه وبالتالي الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات
بالطبع يعني تكرار الهدى هذا مؤشر ايجابي
هذه الهدنه الثانيه التي تمتد لمده 72
ساعه
صمودها نسبيا يعني يؤشر الى ان هناك
امكانيه لمزيد من التهدئه بين الطرفين
فاعتقادي ان الولايات المتحده الان
بالتنسيق مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وبعض الدول الافريقيه بدات تنخرط بشكل
كبير
ركز على الدور الامريكي في هذه الازمه
الذي بدا يعني يتحول نسبيا الى نوع من
انواع الانخراط السياسي الكبير ومحاوله
تهدئه الامور بقدر الامكان الولايات
المتحده كانت متذبذبه في التعامل مع
الازمه السودانيه منذ سقوط البشير وعادت
كثيرا كانت ترسل وفودا وكانت لا وكانت لا
تقابل
بايجابيات او بحصيله ايجابيه هذه الوفود
هناك نوع من انواع التعثر اصلا في الاداره
الامريكيه في التعامل مع الازمات
الافريقيه وفي مقدمتها السودان نحن نعلم
ان يعني المسؤول او المبعوث الامريكي
للقرن الافريقي تم تغييره اكثر من مره
خلال العامين الماضيين وهذا يؤكد ان هناك
قدر من الارتباك في التعامل مع ازمات
المنطقه الان الولايات المتحده تبدو انها
تعيد التموضع في التعامل مع السودان نحن
ايضا لا ننسى ان الانقلاب العسكري الذي
حدث في 25 اكتوبر 20 21 جاء بعد ساعات من
لقاء وفد امريكي
بالمسؤولين العسكريين في السودان وهذه
كانت اشاره غير ايجابيه للضر الامريكي في
السودان الان الولايات المتحده تحاول ان
تنخرط بشكل كبير وتترك بصمتها لانها تعلم
تماما ان المزيد من الفوضى يعني المزيد من
النفوس للقوى الدوليه المنافسه لها حدث
ذلك في سوريا وحدث ذلك في افغانستان ثم
حدث ايضا في ليبيا بالاضافه الى الى دخول
هذه الهدنه بالتنسيق طبعا مع السعوديه
فيما يتعلق بتطورات الازمه هل هناك مواقف
امريكيه واضحه تدل على المسار الذي تتحدث
عن موقف امريكي جديد واكثر
ربما
تدخل او اكثر حرصا على حل الازمه في
السودان
اعتقد ان هناك تحركات يمكن ان لم تظهر حتى
الان لكن هناك احاديث حول اللقاء يمكن ان
يعقد في المملكه العربيه السعوديه بين
البرهان وبين حمدتي لا يمكن ان يحدث ذلك
الا اذا كانت الولايات المتحده بذلت جهودا
كبيره في هذا السياق اعتقد ان حدوث ذلك او
الحديث عنه يعني ان هناك امكانيه لان تهدا
الامور قليلا لان الوضع الحالي وضع الى حد
كبير في قدر من التوازن حتى ولو كانت
القوات المسلحه السودانيه تسيطر على
الاماكن عديده لكن المعارك بدات تدخل في
مرحله من الكر والفر وحرب شوارع وحرب مدن
وهذه المساله تتفوق فيها قوات الدعم
السريع بحكم خبرتها الكبيره في دارفور هذا
نوع من انواع الارهاق يمثل نوع من انواع
الارهاق بالنسبه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
حتى ولو كانت تمتلك الكثير من العداد
والطائرات والاسلحه الثقيله ولكن اساس
يمكن البدء في مفاوضات بين الطرفين كان
هناك خلاف سياسي واضح كان هناك طرف ازمه
المكونه المدنيه المكونه العسكري للانقسام
داخل المكون العسكري اضافه بعدا اخر لهذه
الازمه اذا كان هناك اي اتفاق جديد او اي
مفاوضات جديده ستقوم على اي اساس برايك
اعتقد ان قاعده لا غالب ولا مغلوب هي
القاعده المثاليه في مثل هذه الامور التي
يمكن الاستناد عليها بصرف النظر عما تحقق
هذا عما حقق هذا الطرف من مكاسب عسكريه او
سياسيه او هذا او ذاك الطرف لان المساله
يعني انتصار احدهما لا ينهي المساله لان
ستكون هناك مجموعات او نتوءات عسكريه يمكن
ان تقاتل في اماكن مختلفه بالذات بالنسبه
للقوات الدعم السريع اذا هزمت في معركه
الخرطوم وهذه المساله صعب حدوثها يعني
بشكل كامل سيمكن ان تتموضع وتنتفع حول في
داخل منطقه دارفور ولديها نفوس قبل
يواجهها واقليمي كبير جدا تستطيع ان
تستثمره في الضغط على اي حكومه سودانيه
وعلى القوات المسلحه السودانيه هذه
المساله يمكن ان تجبر كل طرف على انه لابد
ان يجلس على دوله المفاوضات هناك قاعده
سودانيه ان كل الحروب التي دارت بين
الاداره المركزيه او الحكومات المركزيه
الحركات المسلحه انتهت او تم الجلوس على
طاوله المفاوضات في لحظه معينه كان
للرئيس الامريكي الاسبق جيمي كارتر كلمه
في غايه الاهميه والدلاله بالنسبه للسداد
كان وسيطا في مفاوضات نفاشا 2005 بين
الحكومه السودانيه وبين الحركه الشعبيه
لتحرير السودان ايام الراحل جون جراند كان
يتعجب ويقول انه في الوقت الذي كان يتبادل
فيه الالتهامات كل طرف للاخر عندما يجلسون
على المفاوضات ياخذون ياخذون بعضهم
بالاحضان هذا ما يعني
في كل ربما تقاتل العربيه ولكن التحدي
الاهم
الارواح التي ازهقت هذه الخسائر سواء كان
في الارواح في الممتلكات هناك حرب شوارع
دارت في العاصمه الخرطوم
المدنيين كانوا لمده ما يقارب الان 11
يوما لم يتمكنوا من الوصول الى المساعدات
الانسانيه والغذائيه كل هذه الاحداث وكل
هذه التجاوزات في حقوق الانسان ستمر هكذا
مرور الكرام فقط من اجل الوصول الى هدنه
او سلام منقوص
بالطبع الاحداث الانسانيه هي التي ادت الى
فرد هذه الهدنه فرضا لان المجتمع الدولي
لن يتحمل
وقوع المزيد من الضحايا كنا نتحدث عن بضع
عشرات ثم مئات ثم الاف الان من الضحيه
وهذا الوضع الانساني سيزداد سوءا مع نقص
الادويه مع خروج الكثير من المستشفيات
خارج نطاق الخدمه مع صعوبه الوصول اساسا
دي المشافي في السودان ما لم يكن هناك
هدنه صامده سيكون من الصعوبه ان يتم
الحديث عن
تهدئه مستقره سيكون من الصعوبه الحديث عن
تقليل حجم الخسائر وبالتالي هنا كل طرف
يحاول الالتزام او يوحي بالالتزام بالهدنه
وبوقف اطلاق النار في هذه المده المحدده
ليؤكد انه غير راغب في استمرار الحرب قد
يفهم ذلك على انه نوع من انواع الضعف او
نوع من انواع يعني الندره في الاستمرار في
القدره على الاستمرار في المعارك العسكريه
لكنه هو في النهايه استجابه لمجتمع الدولي
بدا يركز على السودان فيما يتعلق باجلاء
الرعايه واجلاء الاجانب واجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه هذه المساله التعاون فيها من
قبل الطرفين اكد الى حد كبير ان هناك
امكانيه للجلوس مره اخرى على طاوله
المفاوضات محمد ابو الفضل مدير تحرير
جريده الاهرام والمختص في شارع الافريقي
شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا عشره ايام مرت وصراع مستمر وتداعياته
كارثيه على الاقتصاد السوداني اقتصاد
مهترئ في الاساس رغم غير السودان بالموارد
الطبيعيه ومع توقف مطار الخرطوم عن العمل
خسرت الخزينه السودانيه نصف قيمه صادراتها
فيما انزلق سعر الصرف الى ادنى مستويات
عكاز الاقتصاد السوداني هوت فالاخير كان
متكئا على حافه الانهيار حتى قبل بدء صراع
الجنرلين لي الذراع الاقتصاديه تمثل بخروج
مطار الخرطوم عن الخدمه اولا ما افقد
خزينه الدوله اكثر من 50% من صادرات
البلاد اي صادرات الذهب المقدره بملياري
دولار توقف عمل المطار عطل خمسه في المئه
من اجمالي الصادرات والواردات فيما طالت
معدلات التضخم عتبه الستين في المئه ارقام
وصفها مراقبون بغير الدقيقه مضيفين ان
التضخم فوق ذلك بكثير نسبه مماثله قدرت
عند قياس معدل الفقر والذي يتجاوز 60 في
المئه فاكثر من اربعين فيلما من
السودانيين قابعون في خانه البطاله اما
سعر صرف العمله فتدهور بشكل كبير خلال
الفتره الانتقاليه وايام الصراع الاولى
مسجلا انخفاضا قياسيا امام الدولار ليصل
الى 600 جنيه حاليا هذه الارقام قد تصبح
خجوله اذا ما اتسعت رقعه الصراع الجغرافيه
الضيقه والمنحصره بالخرطوم حاليا ففي حين
توقف مطار الخرطوم الا ان الموانئ لا تزال
تعمل سته عشره ولايه سودانيه لم تتاثر
بالنزاع حتى اللحظه بينها الولايات
الشرقيه مثل الجضارف وكسلا وبورتسودان
وولايه نهر النيل وهي تؤمن الطرق من موقع
الموانئ الى العاصمه
لكن في حال تمددت رقعه الحرب سيتاثر
الاحتياطي المحلي الاجمالي وسيتفاقم
التضخم وتنهار قيمه العمله اكثر واكثر
فخمسه وثمانون في المئه من حجم الصادرات
والواردات الكليه البالغه 15 مليار دولار
سنويا تتم عبر الموانئ البحريه في
بورتسودان والبحر الاحمر فيما العشره في
المئه المتبقيه تشق طريقها الى الجاره
المصريه عبر ميناءاي ارجين وشكات
الثقل الاقتصاد المترتب على دول محيطه
بالسودان يبدا بعبر اللاجئين لكنه يمر
حصرا ببوابه بحريه واسعه من بورسودان
هي احدى بوابات السودان الطبيعيه الشرقيه
على البحر الاحمر وتبعد عن العاصمه
الخرطوم
675 كيلومترا يبلغ طول الساحل البحري
السوداني اكثر من 2000
كيلو متر تقريبا ما يجعله واحدا من اطول
السواحل البحريه في العالم ميناء بورتودان
افتتح منذ 114 عاما وتبلغ ساعاته اليوم
مليونا وثلاثه الف حاويه سنويا ويعد
البناء الرئيسي في السودان وواحده من اكثر
الموانئ كفاءه في افريقيا [__] ميناء
متخصصه موارد متخصصه مجموعه من الموانئ
المتخصصه وبينها البناء الجنوبي وهو مخصص
للحاويات ويستخدم كمنفذ رئيس الاستيراد
الصراع الاستراتيجيه مثل الوقود والقمح
والسكر اما ميناء سواكن فمخصص لنقل
المسافرين وصادرات الماشيه بينما ميناء
بشائر خاص بعمليه تصدير نطق دوله جنوب
السود
لدول حبيسه اي تلك التي لا تملك واجهه
بحريه مثل اثيوبيا وجنوب السودان فاقتصاد
جنوب السودان قائم بنسبه 95% على عائدات
النفط واي عرقله او اغلاق ستكون كارثيه
على الطرفين حيث تصدر جوبا 170 الف برميل
يوميا عبر خط انابيب يمر بجارتها الشماليه
اي من جوه مباشره لبرسودان الخرطوم تستفيد
في المقابل من تحصيل رسوم عبور النفط
والمقدر بثلاث مئه مليون دولار سنويا
الميناء اصبح مؤخرا مركزا للتنافس الدولي
والاقليميته لحمايه امن البحر الاحمر الذي
يعبر منه نحو 20% من التجاره العالميه
و30% من تجاره
[موسيقى]
مشاهد لما الت اليه الاوضاع في منطقه
الشنبات بالخرطوم بحري عقب المعارك
العنيفه والقصف الجوي خلال الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع دمار
هائل في هذه المنطقه فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
تعتبر صدام من اكثر الدول الافريقيه التي
لها حدود مشتركه مع الدول المجاوره نتعرف
على الدول المحاذيه للسودان وممراتها
البحريه والبحريه
جمهوريه السودان محاطه بعده دول من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تحدها سبعه دول شمالا وغربا
وجنوبا مع تعدد المعابر البريه والممرات
المائيه لها الجاره الشماليه مصر تتشارك
مع السودان بحدود طولها
1276 كيلومترا في منطقه صحراويه بشكل عام
وبها معبران رئيسيه هما اشكيت وارجين
ليبيا على الجهه الاخرى تربطها بالسودان
حدود تمتد لثلاثمائه 182 كيلومترا في بيئه
تتنوع تضاريسها ما بين صحراء وجبال وسهول
يوجد معبر واحد بين الدولتين هو العوينات
قرب المثلث الحدودي بين الدولتين ومصر
وفي الجهه الشرقيه من السودان وممراتها
البحريه على البحر الاحمر فهي تضم مينا
اين رئيسيين هما ميناء بورتسودان وسواكن
حسن غوليد العربيه
ينضموا الينا من الخرطوم اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي في مركز الدراسات الدوليه
اهلا بك دكتور امين الى اي مدى يمكن القول
بان هذه الهدنه وصمد حتى الان وهل هناك
اساسيات لصمود اي هدنه وان تكون ناجحه
صباح الخير مرحب بك ومرحب بالساده
المشاهدين هذه الهدنه طلعها للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
ويمكن ده اللي مديها هو وتاثير على
الطرفين حتى الان
ونشهد الان هدوء في كل المناطق بصوره
مطلقه
لم تشتكي اي جهه من وجود اي اشتباكات خرج
المواطنون الان
للتسوق والى المستشفيات والى لمس شمل
الوزر اعتقد انه يمكن تطوير هذه الهدنه
الى هدنه اطول وصولا الى وقف اطلاق النار
مع دعمها
بالاليات المناسبه
للفصل بين المجموعتين
ويحقق الهدف الرئيسي منها القتال ومعالجه
ان واحد الانسانيه ولكن هل من الممكن وجود
قوات دوليه او قوات افريقيا او حتى عربيه
في الخرطوم
ما بين طرفي الصراع
اذا المبادره الشعبيه مبادره الحكماء الان
هي تشمل مجموعه من الحكماء والقيادات
الوطنيه والادارات
الصوفيه هذه المبادله لو تمكنت من النجاح
لا نحتاج الى قوات فصل من الخارج
لكن اذا تعسرت هذه المبادره الوطنيه
رد يحتاج الامر الى وجود فصل بين
المجموعتين وهذا يعني تدخل الخارجي لكن
نامل
ان تكون الاحوال تحت النظره الوطنيه من
جانب
الطرفين ومن جانب ايضا
القوه السياسيه التي ايضا لديها مبادره
تقوم بها الان واضح انه مساله الحسد
قد لا تكون هي الفيصل ولكن المواد المسلحه
الان تسيطر على كل المناطق عاده تلفزيون
القومي للعمل المناطق السياديه والعسكريه
الان تحت السيطره لذلك المطلوب فقط
والان النواحي الانسانيه واعتقد الطرف
الاخر الان يرغب
ايجاد مخرج له في ايجاد مخرج للنواحي
الانسانيه التي تسبب فيها بهذا التمرد طيب
بالتاكيد نحو الانسانيه مهمه جدا ولكن ما
الذي يجعل مثلا القوات المسلحه توافق على
هذه الغنه وهي قد كما اشرت قبل قليل سيطره
الكثير من المناطق الاستراتيجيه بعد
مناوشاتها مع قوات الدعم السريع
وهذا المسلحه مسؤوله عن الامن الوطني
مسؤوله عن حدود البلاد مسؤوله عن
المواطنين
مسؤوله عن تحقيق التوازن الاجتماعي
والسياسي والامني داخل البلاد لذلك من ضمن
مسؤولياتها اعتقد انها راعت الموقف
الانساني وبالتالي قبلت بالهدنه باعتبار
ان هنالك
اشكاليات كبيره في المستشفيات في
الوزراءات خروج حتى الجاليات الاجنبيه
التي تريد الخروج من السودان كل هذه
العوامل ادت الى هذا القبول ولكن هي ممسكه
بمفاصل الامر حتى اذا حدث اي تجاوز من
الطرف الاخر الدعم السريع يمكن ان تتدخل
وهذا ما حدث في الهدنه الاولى والثانيه
والثالثه كان هنالك خرق من من الطرف الاخر
وبالتالي قوات المسلحه تحسم الامر في
الايام العشر الماضيه
واعتقد انه هذه الهدنه يمكن تطويرها من
اجل مصلحه البلاد ومن اجل مصلحه المواطن
السوداني هل هو الدكتور امين اسماعيل
مجدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
اظهر شريط مصور عددا من القتلى لقوه الدعم
السريع في مقر النور القبه في مدينه
الفاشر شماله ولايه دارفور
وفي شريط مصور اخر يظهر او يظهروا حجم
اسنادات الجيش السوداني القادمه من ولايات
النيل الابيض والدريل
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عمليات مستمره من بورت معنا من هناك
الزميل نزار بقداوي اهلا بك نزار كيف هي
الصوره لديك
الصوره كما تتابعونها الان من خلف مباشره
عبر هذا النقل المباشر لقناه العربيه من
داخل الميناء الاخضر بميناء بورسودان
تحديدا في الميناء الشمالي
292 من رعايه دوله الهند في السودان
ووصلوا الى هذه المرحله بعد ان اكملوا
كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه باجلائهم من
السودان هنالك نحو 550 ايضا من افراد
الجاليه الهنديه او الرعايه الهنود في
السودان وصلوا امس وامس الاول الى مدينه
بورسودان شرقه السودان
لاستكمال الاجراءات المتعلقه بترحيلهم
واجلائهم من شرق السودان الى ميناء جده
ومنها مباشره الى دوله الهند عبر الخطوط
الجويه
الهنديه هذه الاعداد المقدره من الهنود
تضاف اليها ايضا عدد من البعثات وعدد من
رعايا الدول الحديث هنا عن ما قامت به
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
امس وامس الاول
لعدد من الجاليات العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه وصلوا الان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بعد قليل ايضا ستصل قطعه
بحريه فرنسيه
من موظفي الامم المتحده في السودان
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه هنا هنا في بورسودان
حيث وصلت امس وامس الاول هنالك ايضا عدد
من رعايا اندونيسيا وعدد من الدول في
طريقهم من الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان
لاستكمال الاجراءات
الاجلاء سواء كان عبر الميناء هنا في
بورسودان او عبر الجو ايضا في مدينه
بورسودان هذه القطعه البحريه الان
تحتاج الى ما يقارب الساعه
لاستكمال اجراءات اجراء كل من وصل الى هذه
المنطقه في الميناء الاخضر بعدها مباشره
ستحط في ذات المكان قاعده بحريه ايضا تتبع
لدوله الهند وعلى متنها ايضا القوات
البحريه الخاصه التي ايضا تعمل على تامين
وتعمل بتنسيق مع الجيش السوداني الذي يشرف
بصوره كامله على عمليات الاجلاء بتنسيق
ايضا مع الوحدات الاداريه في الشرطه ومع
البعثات ومع وزارات الخارجيه في عدد من
الدول اذا عمليه الاطلاع مستمره من ميناء
بوتسودان كما نتابع مع زميل نزار بقداوي
بتحديد من قسم الميناء الاخضر داخل هذا
البناء فالغسل قليلا نزار فيما يتعلق
بعمليات الاجلاء ما الاليه المتبعه دائما
لاجلاء الرعايه هل
يتم توجه اي شخص يريد مثلا الخروج من
السودان الى الميناء بشكل مباشر ام ان
جهات ما هي من تقوم بتنظيم عمليه خروج
اولئك الرعايه من العاصمه الخرطوم او من
بقيه المدن السودانيه
هذا الامر يتم على هذا النحو البعثات
الدبلوماسيه السفارات هي من يفتح الباب
اولا هي من يبدا المرحله الاولى بجمع
اسماء الراغبين في الخروج
وزاره الخريه ايضا تنسق عبر البعثات
الدبلوماسيه البعثات الدبلوماسيه تنسق مع
اللجنه العليا المشرفه على عمليه الاجلاء
هذه اللجنه تنقسم الى شقين لجنه الاجلاء
عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
ولجنه الاجلاء عبر ميناء بورسودان الدولي
كلا اللجمتين برئاسه ضابط رفيع برتبه طيار
بحري
ولواء في
الجناح العسكريه البحري في السودان
اللجنه تقوم بالتنسيق وباستلام الطلبات من
البعثات الدبلوماسيه تراجع الكشوفات عبر
وزاره الداخليه السودانيه تحديدا قسم
الجوازات والهجره والجنسيه هو من يشرف على
حجم اعداد الصفات التي تصل الى بورسودان
يتم حصر الاعداد يتم توجيه من وصل الى
بورسودان من الرعايه ومن ممثل البعثات
الدبلوماسيه الى مقر سكنيه الى فنادق الى
مؤقته يتم تنظيم عمل هذه اللجان عبر
الايواء وعبر الغذاء وعبر تقديم الخدمات
الصحيه والعلاجيه ان تطلب الامر ذلك بعد
ذلك يتم حصر كل الكشوفات في اللجنه العليا
التي يشرف عليها الجيش وتشرف عليها ايضا
وحدات دبلوماسيه لكن لسهوله هذا الامر
وحتى يمضي بسلاسه ارطاءه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وارطات عدد من الدول ان يتم
التنسيق عبر جهه موحده وتم التوافق على ما
يبدو ان تكون المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي
من يشرف بالتنسيق مع الجيش على اخراج نسبه
كبيره من رعايه الدول وهذا ما اكده يوم
امس سفير المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
السودان علي بن حسن جعفر عندما تحدث
للعربيه وقال بان جهود المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تمضي بالتنسيق والتشاور مع مختلف
الدول لتسهيل مهام اجراءات نقل واجلاء
الرعايه وهنالك طلبات ايضا وصلت الى
السفاره السعوديه
للاسهام من قبل السعوديه في ترتيب عمليات
الاجلاء السعوديه بحكم القرب الجغرافي
ايضا وبحكم التنسيق يمن يسهل هذا الامر
وهذه الاعداد ستصل بعد ساعتين او ثلاث الى
مدينه جده في الجانب الاخر من البحر الى
بلدانهم ايضا نتابع جانبا من المشهد من
الحدود المصريه السودانيه هناك ايضا
عمليات اجلاء عبر هذا المنفذ البري وتابع
التفاصيل مع الزميل احمد عثمان احمد ما
لديك
اهلا بك بالفعل استمرار لعمليات الاجلاء
من معبر ارقين الحدودي البري ما بين مصر
والسودان يعني ربما خلال الايام الماضيه
هناك
الالم هؤلاء سواء من المصريين
وايضا من دول اخرى كانت هناك تنسيق ما
بينها وما بين الدوله المصريه والتي
بدورها
ايضا من الاطراف السودانيه
لوجود ممرات امنه لضمان خروج هؤلاء او
عمليات الاجلاء التي تتم بريا في موازاه
ذلك ايضا هناك عمليات اجلاء تمت من خلال
الطيران ربما المشكله بان ما بين هذا
المنفذ ومدينه الخرطوم حوالي 900 كيلو متر
هناك مليانه بان هذه مسافه طويله قد تعرض
اصحابها للمخاطر لكن استطيع ان اقول لك
بانني رايت عدد من المسلمين من كبار السن
واي عدد من السودانيين الذين تحدثوا عن
هذه الرحله للوصول الى هذا البنفرز هناك
ربما علامات سعاده لنجاحهم في الوصول
بعد رؤوه خلال الايام
الماضيهم قرار يعني جريء بالجوء الى
المسار البري للوصول الى معبر ارقين في
مصر في هذا المعبر هناك ايضا الاستقبال
الكثير من المصريين والسودانيين ايضا رايت
خلال الساعات الماضيه عدد من اعضاء الوفود
الدبلوماسيه الاجنبيه الذين جاؤوا الى هذا
المعبر للاشراف والتنسيق بخروج مواطنيهم
من السودان الى مصر كان هناك تنسيق ما بين
عدد من الدول الاوروبيه تحديدا والحكومه
المصريه هناك اهتمام شديد جدا من جانب
الدوله المصريه عن طريق اكثر من وزاره
واكثر من مؤسسه من خلال التعاون ايضا مع
الوزرائهم في السودان لضمان تامين عمليات
الاجلاء من خلال الممرات الامنه كما ذكرت
لك هناك يعني اهتمام ان يكون هناك العديد
من التسهيلات في موازاه ذلك محمد ربما
هناك ايضا تدقيق امني لا يعني يتعارض مع
هذه التنسيلات هناك من يرى بانها كثير من
الفلول العناصر الاخوانيه التي خرجت من
مصر عام 2013 عن طريق السودان قد يكون
هناك ربما محاوله لعودته مره اخرى ولكن
هذا لا يؤثر على عمليات الخروج
عليها الى اكثر من مكان اقرب مكان فيه
فنادق ربما للراحه هي مدونه مدينه ابو
سمبل على بعد 150 كلم المركز الاكبر بعدها
هو في مدينه اسوان على بعد 400 كلم هناك
من يتحرك من خلال مطار اسوان الى القاهره
وهناك من يتخذ من الحافلات للرجوع الى
مدنهم وقراهم هنا في مصر اذا هذا هو
المشهد من المعبر ارقين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه كما تابعنا مع الزميل
احمد عثمان وكما تتحدث صوره من ميناء بورت
سودان مع الزميل نزار بقداوي في عمليه
استمرار
خروج الكثير من الرعايه الاجانب من
السودان بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره وكما
نتابع قوات المسلحه البحريه الهنديه تقوم
بادلاء الرعايه الهنود من بورتسودان الى
ميناء جده ومن هناك الى بلدانهم عبر
طائرات او عبره وسائل نقل مختلفه اذا
عمليات الاجلاء بتنسيق ما بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وسلطات السودانيه المختصه وعدد من الدول
الاجنبيه الحريصه على اجلاء رعاياها في
هذه المرحله
ايضا علاقه صداقه وتحالف جمعت الفريق اول
محمد حمدان وعبد الفتاح البرهان بدات منذ
نحو 20 عاما عندما قاتل الطرفان في خندق
واحد في معارك دارفور
ازدادت هذه العلاقه متانا مع التطورات
السياسيه في السودان وصولا الى اسقاط حكم
البشير لكن لا شيء ثابت في السياسه
واصدقاء الامس صاروا اعداء اليوم وانتهت
العلاقه الحبيبيه بمعارك طاحنه بين طرفك
وصلح متي الى ولايه نهر النيل زياره خاصه
الى منزل البرهان استقبال بحفاوه ونقاش
حميمي حول مستقبل السودان
هذه الصور كانت قبل نحو عام حليفه الامس
صراع عدوين فلا شيء ثابت بالسياسه
[موسيقى]
قبل نحو 20 عاما كان اللقاء الاول بين
قطبي الصراع في السودان التقى احمد مكي
والبرهان في دارفور قاتلا في خندق واحد
بعد 12 عاما تشاؤل اقدار ان يتقاطع طريقان
الرجلين مجددا
ويتفقا على ارسال قوات مشتركه من الدعم
السريع والجيش للمشاركه مع قوات التحالف
في اليمن كل
الغروب رجل واحد
تعززت العلاقه بين احمد والبرهان لتصل في
العام 2019 الى دعم الحراك الشعبي للاطاحه
بحكم البشير
في وحدتنا كلنا قلنا الكلام ده قلنا قوتنا
في وحدتنا وما زلنا بنقول الكلام ده في كل
يوم يعني قوتنا في وحدتنا نحن وحدتنا
وتماسكنا هي
وحده السودان
واليوم ينفرط عقد التحالف بين حميتي
والبرهان فالسودان كاي سفينه لا يمكن ان
يقودها قبطان
[موسيقى]
ومع نهايه هذه الساعه من التقدير اتوقف مع
موجز لاهم الانباء اكد رئيس دائره وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه للرقابه على التسلح في
ان مخاطر المواجهه العسكريه المباشره بين
القوتين النوويتين روسيا والولايات
المتحده في ازدياد مستمر واضاف يرباكوب
انه اذا تطورت الاحداث وفقا للسناريو
الاسوا واستمرت واشنطن في اتباع مسار
المواجهه مع موسكو فان مصير معاهده ستارت
قد يصبح محسوما وسيكون من الضروري القلق
بشان مصير العالم ككل اعلنت قوه المهام
المشتركه التابعه للتحالف الدولي ضد داعش
اعتقال اربعه عناصر من التنظيم خلال
عمليات قادتها قوته سوريا الديمقراطيه في
الرقه بشمال شرق سوريا وقالت القوه في
بيان لها ان اعتقال العناصر الاربعه جاء
خلال عمليات بحث عن الاسلحه والمتفجرات
بهدف تفكيك شبكات تنظيم داعش واكدت انها
تواصل تحقيق نتائج ناجحه من خلال العمليات
التي تقودها قصد في محافظه الرقه
اعلن مكتب الامير العام للامم المتحده ان
انتونيكوتيرش ناقش مع وزير الخارجيه
الروسي س الوضع في اوكرانيا وسوريا
وافغانستان وضف بياناتي وزير الخارجيه
الروسي رساله الى الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
تحتوي على مقترحات لتحسين تنفيذ صفقه
الحبوب مع الاخذ في الاعتبار المواقف التي
اعربت عنها الاطراف مؤخرا وتهديدات الامن
الغذائي العالمي
اعلن وزير الخارجيه التركي
القمه بين رؤساء روسيا وايران وتركيا
وسوريا قد يعقد مطلع مايو المقبل
وقالوا انه لم يتم بعد الاتفاق على موعد
محدد لان الرئيس الايراني يعتزم زياره
سوريا في ذات الفتره والعمل جار على
الاتفاق على الموعد تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
التركي تاتي عشيه الاجتماع الرباعي لوزراء
الدفاع وقاده الاستخبارات للدول الاربع في
موسكو اليوم
في باكستان قتل 13 شخصا في انفجارين
لمستودعي ذخيره تابع لمكتب مكافحه الارهاب
في شمال غرب باكستان وقال المتحدث باسم
الشرطه الباكستانيه ان الانفجارين ليس
نتيجه هجوم انتحار على الارجح وان النيران
اشتعلت في مستودع الذخيره بسبب ماس
كهربائي ويجري التحقيق في ملابسات الحادث
الذي ادى بحسب اداره احد مستشفيات المنطقه
الى اصابه عده جرحى بعضهم في حال حرجه
طالب رئيس الوزراء الاسكتلنديه الجديد
حمزه يوسف رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بتحويله
لاجراء استفتاء جديد حول استقلال بلاده
حسب ما افادت صحيفه
وذكرت الصحيفه ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسكتلندي قد اعرب خلال لقائه الاول
برئيس الوزراء البريطاني عن امله في ان
يحترم التطلعات الديمقراطيه للبرلمان
الاسكتلندي ويمنح له صلاحيات لاجراء
الاستفتاء واضافت الصحيفه ان سوناك اقترح
على يوسف ردا على طلبه العمل على خفض غلاء
المعيشه في بريطانيا بدلا من الاستفتاء
على الاستقلال
اعلم الملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك انه
سيعمل على تحسين شفافيه والانصاف على موقع
التدوينات القصيره تويتر وضف ماسك في
تغريده على منصته انه لا يزال هناك الكثير
من العمل الذي يتعين القيام به
ساعطينا الاخباريه انتهت
لكنها تغطيه معتبره على مدار الساعه
لمتابعه اخر تطورات المشهد في السودان
اترككم مع هذه التغطيه على راس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات